I love internet
crashes just love me some internet
crashes stupid Linux drivers I
swear so
bad
G so
dumb well we're back
oops let's see where stuff
went um
I wish wish I could evaluate one of
their
checkpoints I mean they run for like a
billion freaking steps I could do that
overnight I
like the fact this is not consistent is
very
annoying I don't know why Wan be is this
like a wanb setting that it's like
screwing with all my sampling
run it's like it's annoying because it's
like oh just solve like a 100 scenes or
whatever and it'll work on way more but
it doesn't freaking
here we
[Music]
go for
now we perf optimize the heck out of
this
thing shouldn't take long I've already
done the work I just have
to fix the stuff that they slow
one this goes to
oops 7
six uh 16 K
them oh yeah this
matches and
up to me now
to make of this work
let's see what we get perf
wise oh for [ __ ] sake
Madrona
freaking going Port this thing to CPU
and it's going to be faster
that'd be
funny I do not have time to do that now
though that'll be after I clear and
carbs and client
work every damn thing
us how's the end keep freaking getting
slower
what the
hell dude the end every single time I
check back the end is like somehow
slower it's supposed to be a million
steps a second and it's somehow slower
every G like damn time
I don't know how it is that every single
time it's like something changes that
shouldn't matter it's Sim is just 10x
slower again like this engine is just
not
good either that or they're using it
wrong so
it's like good in theory if you have
everything configured perfectly but as
soon as you want to do like variable
numbers of Agents or different scenes or
whatever it just
breaks okay we're going to do
Network I'm changing their net
again getting rid of Dropout layer norm
and all that s
this
there
200 what does a guy have to do to get
his old perf back like I don't know what
the
heck like every single time
matter so
how what the heck was it
man what did they
maybe at input
dim for
this how many more viewers are there six
we lost internet for a
bit freaking Linux drivers I swear
yeah after it
crashed stupid I got to fix the drivers
I don't know what's wrong with
it
yeah I don't care I'm doing work I'm
trying to make progress on this
obnoxious it's like every time I like I
turn like every time I look away the
perace back to what like the original
troll this was 250 mil this was
250 I don't know why it's no longer 250
and it drives me insane
I work and I perf optimize stuff and it
gets
slow
somehow oh was it
this might have been this
okay that's it back to
perf it'll go up a little more with more
num
50k steps per
second with full
optimizations look if you tell me your m
is a million steps per second and I
strip all the overhead and it's 50k like
I can't do anything about that it's just
like your en isn't as fast as you
thought sorry
here it drops from 250 instantly just
when you use their train
data you know I'm going to try something
real
quick well yeah I mean that's the claim
with GPU drive it's a million steps per
second and it is under fully optimal
conditions you're just never going to
see those conditions
unfortunately
um I do this I don't I don't care at
this point I'm just going to try to well
maybe get this one I'll
leave I just do this
anything you would think this would do
something if this doesn't
how the [ __ ] does that not
work
warning how do I host an interactive C
CAD mod learn C C+ Ray that be easy put
it on the web compiles to web assembly
trivial
I don't know why you're messing with the
abenes thingy but all
you realize that half the people you're
responding to are Bots like Nori is a
bot
I don't see how I guess it's if it
encounters something that's more it
doesn't prune correctly Maybe
yeah I literally can't do [ __ ] for them
because this the Sim just straight up
isn't as fast as they said so like I
can't
do not on the the main scenes at least
you'd have to filter
forgot hey how's it
going currently we are attempting to
perf optimize this
thing ality there's no
alacrity you're looking at
vim and that's about
it I don't even have Neo on this
container or any like
anything this is just uh
whatever well there's no t-u cuz this is
my local box so who
cares
um I have t-u on
servers on my
we don't even have any spare memory to
run more
environments it's so freaking memory
expensive honestly I think it's like
it's not even the scenes
like you can set this to one and it's
like it like doesn't even scale this way
as far as I can
tell it's not even like you just need
the same scene constantly
not zoom terminal
is what's the project what are you
doing yeah I've been coding a while um
you can see this at puffer doai we do
ultra high performance reinforcement
learning
I also help currently this is for uh an
academic lab I do some stuff for them so
this is one of our
MS all of our M are right here you can
see agents playing all of these live you
can play them yourself they run right in
your browser this is a trained agent I
can hold shift oops I can hold shift and
now I'm playing it so you can take over
and try them all out
yourself uh we got docs we got blogs we
got
articles and everything's free and open
source right here we got a Discord with
a whole bunch of helpful people in it if
you're trying to get into
RL and I've got an X where I post a
whole bunch of RL stuff and some extra
articles for
funsies and the occasional Fitness thing
but mostly
RL and I stream all the dev so that's
what this is we're fixing RL we're
making it Ultra fast Ultra stable all
that good stuff
info check the repo yeah I mean check
out the Discord as well we got lots of
fun people around for uh RL stuff I mean
you just pretty much need a programming
background to get into it that's about
it I really don't know what to do about
this though because this number is not
going to go any higher
and the you got to know how to code
that's
it I can teach people how to write
better code but not how to
code what did you I this is not on me
now this is on the
Sim all I did was load their main data
files so it seems that whatever they
have in the examples is like Optimal
conditions
um and whatever's in the training is not
optimal M really don't know what to do
with this is the thing because
like you can't really do anything with
50k it's too
slow I mean that's like a billion an
hour to a billion 10
hours well you were running I was
running the example scene just different
data files that they gave me for testing
but it seems like their actual data
files are substantially
slower I mean unless I'm do I don't
think I'm doing anything stupid here
well I mean I could rewrite this an and
it would be a million steps a
second I I'm not doing it now obviously
but we can look at it it's
like I don't think it's that
crazy like we could do the render very
easily I think that the main thing
it's so there's a 700 some modline Sim
it's just using all this weird entity
component
like there's like basic collision and
stuff but
we could do this with or probably even
without box
with madron we don't need
this that's
nothing 500 lines of oh these are just
structs
redundant
OB
tiny okay this has some
code yeah but this is
right and then there's CPU stuff I
wouldn't worry about
this level gen not that
bad they got a Cann in
here in
it I mean there's like
maybe 2,000 lines of like real code in
here or
less map
R yeah it's not that
bad it would probably need either box 2D
or we'd have to do our Min version of
mean I wonder if anybody in the Discord
would actually like to help with
this I could definitely get it set up in
started it's like I'm tempted to do this
one myself but this one would take I
mean it would take a bit of
work render probably wouldn't be that
bad could probably make it substantially
better as well
work
well no we could definitely get at a
million we can definitely get this a
million it's not like it's not that
heavy of an Environ ironment
it's just a pain because it's like it's
hard to get people from Academia to
actually help on this type of stuff cuz
there're always like papers papers
papers and it's
like you can't you got to invest in your
infra or it's just going to be too slow
for you to do anything and you're just
going to be sad and that's just how it's
going to be
I
mean I'm trying to think what I can even
do with
this I can technically run a hyper
parameter
sweep like the with these
pams what we got Lambda Gamma entropy
right I mean I may as well it's kind of
free but it's just like it's pretty
silly no I mean maybe I can find him
somewhat better hyper
parameters they like look they literally
haven't tuned the hyper parameters at
all because of how slow it is you see
this zero hyper parameter
tuning
zero it's like the most important thing
to do in the field and they can't even
do it because the thing is too slow
I mean I could tune on the example M's
and hope that that transfers but you
know I doubt
it yeah the thing that actually fix the
problem here would
be May maybe I could do it if I were
like on point I could maybe do it in a
couple
weeks it's a fair bit of work to put in
for a for a
collab and the thing is people are so
freaking dumb that they'll like they'll
count um High per against you like even
so GPU drive at the very least they
released it training at like 30,000 30
something thousand steps per second I
got a DM I got people like telling me
that like it's too simple because it was
90% solved on day one whereas this other
SIM has been out for years and isn't
solved and the other SIM runs 10 steps
per second so it's fundamentally
impossible you
I mean I wonder how much time it would
take to get the basics in place you
know I really don't like the Box 2D
dependency as the problem I really don't
like the freaking physics Sim dependency
it's such a pain
like we should just have our own like
basic set of physics utils it really
wouldn't be that
hard we just drop them right in the file
for whatever we just like a b like BAS
basic bounding box checks and stuff like
that you know just like angled bounding
box checks stuff like
that couple couple
strs I don't know I kind of want to set
up some other some better hyper prams
stuff at the moment I'm trying to think
I got to do uh client stuff on physics
tomorrow for
sure upgrade from ssw dude have you seen
the stuff I've been building we're
already
while it's not even a difficulty thing
at this point it's a time thing
it's just that 2,000 3,000 lines of code
is 50 lines a page 40 to 60 pages of
code it's just still a bunch of code to
write more gpus less
problems I still got to go receip that
freaking is it just box five that's
acting up that guy or is there other
ones obviously four is
dead currently okay I'll go see if I can
reat it I really hope that the GPU isn't
like somehow
can we get captain to try it on his M to
see if it speeds stuff
uh it's been a fair bit of
work I can't even like submit this as
the thing it's like yeah their current
Network architecture is better and stuff
cuz they're hard bottlenecked on the end
anyways I stripped like all the
overhead what's the
problem I optimize this to a quar
million steps per second up from
35k on uh the example tasks but as soon
as you load the train tasks it drops
right back down to
50K it's just the engine is not
good they have this very F fancy GPU
engine that's great for what it's good
at but this ain't it like they have
because they have variable numbers of
agents and such it's just not good for
but I mean I was assured that it was
going to be
fast I mean unless there's some setting
I'm missing but I don't think there
is I mean I was I shed repeatedly that
this thing
had I mean it it is in the optimal case
it's um I think for any like one scam
size you can probably get it to that
performance but like I think it will
literally be the same amount of code as
it is now if we just do it and
see just the N it's the fact that they
have to load everything into fix size
buffers and uh the train set the train
set is less agent D is lower agent
density than the example set
something like
that that it could technically
be the environment resets or I don't
freaking know I'm tired
um
yeah I mean I did my part I optimized it
as much as it could be
optimized it's it's up a little bit of
performance from
before I cut as much overhead as I could
it scales now so if the Sim as fast
it'll go
bur somewhat disappointing
though all I got time to do at the
moment is potentially queue up some um
queue up some experiments figure out
maybe I can figure out a couple things
on uh on carbs and go to
bed I came up with another good test for
it and some more potential modifications
but I think even the current version
will be
good is it hard to make up
ends yeah they're loaded from Real uh
real traffic scenarios
so that's a data set like each of these
is a real
scenario I don't
know I'm going to go back to my puffer
container
okay let's see how our current
experiments are
going we found a few limitations with
the neoc carbs it's still better than
the old thing by a huge amount but it's
not the god algorithm
yet it's going to take a little more
work to be the god algorithm
yeah so this is an issue it's cost it
might be pushing cost down here a little
bit we'll
see let
say uh
it's not filling in the parito front the
way I would like it
to it's only got 60 runs so maybe by the
end we'll
see I don't
know like to get this running on more
things what was
um hang
on yeah I ran this one
here and hung on this
actually can I see is there anything
suspicious about this triple Triad
curve I should check that
score how's the
oh
cost that high
point is there an infinite in um triple
Triad
this one looks
great oh there is an infinite isn't
there hang
it anything with a noop is has an
infinite
unfortunately if the game doesn't punish
you for
card yeah you can spam select you can
spam uh you can spam select and you can
spam no op
okay
um we're going to have to change some
stuff I
think do you remove well there's no
reason to have a no
Al literally there's no
so we'll just
do if and
vog
set yeah this is gets reset
not really I'm just tired it's just
taking a while
isue so we get
[Music]
action = to
-1 action
equal
stuff you have render
render should have
tick going to go see you
later dude I got to go all the way the
[ __ ] down to the that's happening
tomorrow
oh I
see this goes here
this get stuck instantly it's
weird it's probably in the mend
code whatever I did to that
this I don't know how I could have
possibly broken it
good I'm just going to go GDB this I
don't
oh okay so this is why the the model
needs to be retrained obviously cuz it's
going to try to place the
card forever we just going to try to
place this card
so it's probably just the human actions
that are screwed up
okay it's not passing actions to the
freaking I I know what it is it's just
not passing actions
interesting I appear at the
permissioning [ __ ] with my
Docker I just press three and it
selected card
got place
card action minus
okay and then minus
5 hang
literally L duh
that was
symbolizer
fine here's the
end and we get the
trace which
you know is it this wait card placement
minus
right no that's doesn't
help that screws it up
insane literally how is it this much of
a
mess dude like how
maybe I do
this and then
set
right it's stuck cuz this is an old
model and it's mapping
we'll see if this fixes
it and then I can go to
bed having
accomplished a great many things
faults then we'll call
tonight soon as we get these experiments
up been
running let's see if this egg
faults some
[ __ ] oh
ho so hopefully this makes it impossible
to infinite
loop I would
hope that's what was happening
previously I
believe and was just infinite
looping wasn't getting any logs
see like this for instance did bad to
the pipers
stuck now we'll hope that this is not
you know all of them
do I do something that would break this
or is this just a Bas of
hypers guess we'll find out in a second
but I do want to take a quick look to
make
one so it must just be running out of
time here spamming uh spamming Act or
something it can spam
select but it should be getting a
negative reward for
that hang on what could it actually be
doing think we'll wait for the next
experiment but if the next one is also
like this then
yeah it gets punished for selecting bad
actions
it shouldn't be able to have um a return
of negative one like this
anyways now this is
broken for
for resetting instantly without doing
anything
out that it doesn't get Negative reward
if it
spams that's really clever
actually freaking RL just
now you can't do it anymore can you
haha have defeated
you you semi
sentient reinforcement learning
algorithm and now you shall run many
experiments for me
halting she'll run very very many
experiments without halting
and actually I can go set
the this can be
30 you only you only really need 10
actions you be
20 we'll leave it at 30
the
heck now whatever it'll be the
same rebuild this
one there it
goes oh it is
perfect
[Music]
mode
sweep
oh and I'm so tired I got to get this
done I just gave you my API token stupid
thing give me AP I
took
3.9 I mean what are the odds that that's
literally uh I just saw the actual
training work okay
that could
be what you get for spamming bad
actions that would say that there's no
the seating is working which would be
interesting
I'm going to watch it for a few
minutes see if it's
working I'm going to say that this is
still possibly just very bad hypers
it does but after a bit of
uh uh it's not like locked to
it it could just be that like too high
learning rate or too high whatever
is you know
hypers that's too ambitious it's already
10 I'm going go reply to an email on
this side real
quick and
good
okay you know we're learning stuff here
it's just uh there's some bad hypers in
this environment that you can't get
around apparently they just craft right
out that's fine
we are
good
oops it's
overnight
um do I cue something else
up I guess I may as well
so it'll be 1 through eight I
guess for this
like
eight 1 through eight 2 through
eight 1 through
eight I think one is still
fine yeah cuz it's Vector as two are
good so we have the
rewards we got
58 um
and then
maximize it's
Min com
c so I'll have to add a panel for this
but otherwise this should
be it should be
runs oh wait I have something running
already we're good to go for the evening
I'll let that one finish before I do
anything else we'll be good got both
boxes loaded up
nicely now these two are not at five you
can get lower you can get
higher we're happy uh I'm going to go to
bed for folks
watching you're catching the tail end
when I'm pretty low on energy but um all
of the stuff that I develop is free and
open source right here that we do have
service packages for companies that's
something you're interested
in all of our environments they're super
fast million steps per second per core
you can play them right in your browser
because they're can see compiled to web
assembly and we even have the agents
running on the web as well you can hold
shift and take over for them and try out
all the
environments kind of just watch some of
them are kind of mesmerizing
and if you want to help us out or get
involved start the GitHub really does
help me a
lot and uh you can join the Discord
about 900 people in here lots of
friendly folks building RL environments
you pretty much just need to know how to
code um we make the rest of it pretty
simple to pick up for something so
complex and other than that we've got
docs we've got a Blog with some nice
articles on ourl including nice quick
start guide for
beginners uh we've got some other fun
stuff we're working on and if you want
more
content you can follow me on X where I
post a whole bunch of thoughts on RL as
well as some uh some extra articles that
are not on the
website that's all for tonight I'll be
back tomorrow for most of the day and I
will be working
on uh probably some client stuff I'm
probably going to be doing
uh High
perf simulated humanoid uh humanoid
stuff trying to get like bunch of
humanoids in Sim running nicely in
puffer lib so you can stop by if that's
interesting to you anyways thanks